on poursuit avec Léa Peltier Marcotte
analyste politique et campagne chez
Oxfam Québec bonsoir merci d'être là
pour parler de cette fortune des
milliardaires qui augmentent qui
augmente de plus en plus rapidement
c'est ce que Marie-Claude nous nous
proposait comme chiffre et d'ailleurs je
vous propose un tableau qui illustre la
situation vraiment très très clairement
qui nous montre à quel point cette
fortune augmente de plus en plus
rapidement expliquez-nous ce qu'on voit
et comment on explique ça mais c'est que
en fait il y a eu un effondrement du de
la méthode de taxation des plus riches
donc alors qu'on avait des impôts sur le
revenu plutôt progressif de plus en plus
on sait dirigé dans les années 80 vers
une tendance à moins taxer les
corporations moins taxer les individus
les plus riches parce qu'on croyait que
ça allait bénéficier à tout le monde
mais ce qu'on se rend compte c'est que
c'est illusoire en fait cette théorie là
de dire oui seulement de la prospérité
sur les sur les sur les gens sur la
plupart des gens c'est ça pas dans les
faits et c'est ce qui mène à
une espèce d'accélération de ces de ces
données-là de la fortune des
milliardaires donc des personnes qui
possèdent déjà beaucoup et qui
accumulent les richesses clairement et
effectivement ce graphique là le montre
très très bien est-ce qu'on pourrait
aller jusqu'à dire qu'aujourd'hui les
milliardaires sont presque intouchables
est-ce qu'on peut aller en chercher
davantage oui puis on fait il se passe
les fortunes d'un à l'autre souvent
parce que la plupart des milliardaires
beaucoup de milliardaires sont installés
dans des pays qui taxent ou très peu les
héritages la fortune c'est l'héritage
donc il se partagent une fortune de
parents à enfants allègrement donc ça
crée une espèce ça crée une espèce de
classe aristrue aristocratique de
milliardaire qui ont aussi beaucoup
d'influences dans les milieux
décisionnels et ça fait en sorte
qu'effectivement ça devient une classe
qui est beaucoup d'influence comment on
pourrait faire pour s'assurer de leur
imputabilité ou du moins augmenter et
progressivement la peur
de revenus qu'il paie mais effectivement
quand on parle de d'augmenter la
taxation souvent on se fait pas beaucoup
d'amis mais ce qu'on veut vraiment c'est
que tout le monde fasse ça juste pas et
quand on voit que progressivement les
plus riches pètes de moins en moins
d'impôts réel parce qu'on impose pas
adéquatement leur fortune de façon
générale ou les gains qui font autre que
le revenu que le salaire parce que c'est
là que la les gains des
multimilliardaires et des des
multimillionnaires se font ce sont des
gains autre que le salaire mais on se
rend compte que
c'est pas taxé autant que ça devrait
l'être qui est une chute dans la
taxation donc faudrait rétablir si on
parle pas de ré-ouvrir notre système
fiscal on parle juste de l'optimiser
pour limiter les échappatoires fiscaux
dont possède que possèdent les plus les
plus fortunés parce que bon il y avait
des chiffres qui circulaient aujourd'hui
ont donné l'exemple d'Iron masque parmi
les plus riches du monde évidemment on
parlait d'un taux d'imposition d'à peu
près 3% est-ce que en fait qu'est-ce on
devrait viser ça semble déraisonnable
quand même parce que monsieur madame
tout le monde fait déjà une part
beaucoup plus importante de ses revenus
offices effectivement donc on parle de
personnes qui paient 40%
environ d'impôts sur le revenu comme
vous et moi c'est là-dessus qu'on est
imposé mais il y a 0.4% je crois ou 4
sous sur chaque dollars de recettes
fiscale dans le monde qui provient des
taxes sur la richesse des taxes sur le
patrimoine la plupart c'est les taxes
sur le revenu mais
donc le taux d'imposition effectif des
super riches qui ont des moyens de
déplacer leur fortune et beaucoup moins
de on parle de 3% alors que nous on paie
environ 30 à 40 %. donc faudrait revoir
un peu ces termes-là et même envisager
une taxation de la richesse globale des
plus riches ce que vous proposez
aujourd'hui là c'est dans certains cas
assez ambitieux impôts exceptionnel sur
la seule de solidarité sur la fortune
taxe sur les bénéfices exceptionnels
c'est que vous suggérer aussi le taux
marginal impôt à 60% sur des revenus et
les gains en capital c'est pas un
programme politique d'accord c'est des
idées qu'on donne
c'est pas une approche
une taille unique pour tous les pays au
Canada et on n'est pas en cul de peloton
on taxe déjà de façon progressive et il
y a déjà des taxes assez intéressantes
qui ont été imposées sur les produits de
luxe sur les profits exceptionnels les
entreprises d'assurance financière on
dit juste que il y a un mouvement
continuons à être ambitieux continuons à
être plus ambitieux notamment en
imposant les mieux et en revoyant les
taux d'imposition des gains en capital
et aussi envisager une taxation sur la
richesse vous avez montré les chiffres
une petite imposition un petit
pourcentage je préfère une grande
différence sur nos services publics dans
votre simulation là le chiffre qui qui
était proposé c'était 50 milliards de
dollars par exemple qu'est-ce qu'on
pourrait faire avec ça réinvestir dans
nos infrastructures et investir dans les
systèmes de santé les investissement en
éducation à se préparer à répondre à la
crise climatique aussi aux effets de la
crise climatique et à la maison et
ailleurs aussi augmenter les budgets
d'aide au développement pour justement
réduire les inégalités non seulement
chez nous mais aussi à travers la
planète on montre du doigt évidemment
beaucoup les milliardaires les
ultra-riches mais vous suggérez que les
entreprises aussi ont un rôle à jouer
entre autres et là certaines que tout le
monde
comprend lorsqu'on parle d'inflation
inflation alimentaire en particulier et
en contrepartie des surprofis qui ont
été faites par les entreprises quel rôle
ont-elles à jouer mais c'est ce qui est
intéressant avec le rapport cette année
c'est qu'on voit vraiment cet aspect là
du profit exorbitant des extraordinaire
de certaines entreprises on a certaines
corporations qui ont plus que doubler
leur profit dans les deux dernières
années notamment au niveau de l'énergie
au niveau de l'alimentation
effectivement il y a une espèce de
tempête parfaite de facteurs qui
expliquent ça on a on sort d'une
pandémie il y a la Garonne Ukraine que
un peu déstabilisé toutes les chaînes
d'approvisionnement puis les ressources
naturelles mais il y a des pays qui ont
été innovateurs puis compart
d'innovateurs on parle de quelque chose
qui est déjà été fait avant en temps de
guerre c'est-à-dire une taxe
exceptionnelle en période de crise une
taxe de solidarité donc ceux qui
bénéficient des crises qui augmentent
leur profit en matière lors de crise
sont imposés une petite taxe sur leur
profit excédentaire justement pour que
ce soit mieux redistribué ça c'est déjà
fait auparavant donc on parle que c'est
novateur mais c'est quelque chose qui
est très très ancien en fait l'idée a
déjà circuler ici au Canada mais n'a pas
abouti évidemment c'est qu'il y a pas de
volonté politique c'est un manque de
volonté politique parce que c'est
faisable certains pays comme la Colombie
nous demande que c'est tout à fait
faisable en Colombie non seulement
adopté un nouvel impôt sur la richesse
globale mais aussi un impôt solidaire
sur les compagnies de d'énergie très
intéressante je vous remercie beaucoup
pour cette analyse de ce dossier merci
beaucoup merci à vous
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]